what is probability let me start off
with a question what is the probability
of a pig flying
can a pig fly no it cannot the
probability of a pig being able to fly
is zero okay another one what is the
probability of getting a natural number
on the roll of a fair guy no matter how
the die is rolled you will get a number
between 1 and 6 all of which are natural
numbers the probability is 1 we will
definitely get a natural number on the
roll of a fair die a probability of 0
also means there is a 0% chance of the
event occurring it's an impossible event
on the other hand a probability of 1
tells us there is a hundred percent
chance of the event occurring it is a
certain event that brings us to an
important point in the video the
probability of every event will lie
between 0 and 1 inclusive but how is it
actually defined what is probability
let's call it P the probability of an
event occurring is the number of ways in
which an event can occur over the total
number of possible events number of ways
an event can occur over the total number
of events to understand this well we
look at three examples first the toss of
a fair coin it can either land a head or
a tail now listen to this carefully if
we toss a fair coin what is the
probability that it will land a head
we're just tossing one coin what is the
probability that we will get a head what
is the number of ways in which we can
get a head there's only one way and
that's if it lands ahead and what are
the total possible events we can get a
head or a tail to total
so the probability of getting ahead at
the toss of one fair coin is 1 over 2 of
50% what is the probability of getting a
tail then there's only one way in which
we can get a tail and there are two
possibilities probability of getting a
tail at the toss of a coin is also 50%
now let's look at the case of a fair die
if we roll a fair die it will land one
of these six numbers what is the
probability that the die will land at 3
this one's easy
there's only one way in which we can get
a three and there are a total of six
possibilities the probability of getting
a three at the role of a die is one over
six it's slightly on the lower side okay
so what would be the probability of
getting an odd number at the throw off a
fair die there are three ways in which
we can get an odd number and there are a
total of six possibilities so the
probability of getting an odd number at
the throw of a fair die is three over
six of 50% and the last example is that
of a pack of cards let's assume a pack
of 52 cards say we pick a random card
from this pack what is the probability
that we will pick a jack think logically
how many jacks are there in the entire
pack there are four jacks one in each
suit and the total number of cards is 52
the probability of picking a jack from a
pack of 52 cards here is for over 52 and
here's the last question in this session
what is the probability of picking a
face card
there are 12 face cards Jack Queen and
King in each of the four suits and the
total number of possibilities is 52 the
probability of picking a face card from
a pack of 52 cards is 12 over 52 these
are the three most common types of
problems seen in the exams in the coming
sessions we will solve more problems
based on these three examples
you